Доброго дня всім
як керівник бізнесу асоціації освітніх
закладів і сьогодні
моделюю сесію приватної освіти
приватна освіта Ми сьогодні дуже
розвинута вже галузь в Україні
А це
найбільше роботодавець А це внутрішній
інвестор і наразі
найбільш актуальним питанням у
відновлення освіти в Україні є якраз
залучення внутрішніх інвесторів і
розвиток системи приватної освіти тому
ми тут виділили цього з секцією для
цього запросили
учасників нашої асоціації для
сказали про різні
напрацювання форми проблематику і
спільно щоб ми могли
випрацювати
рекомендації які потім надамо органам
державної влади для
спільної реалізації
в двох словах розповім про нас
приватна освіта на сьогодні об'єднана
бізнес-асоціацію освітніх закладів ми
нараховуємо близько 300 учасників На
сьогодні це приватні школи дитячі садки
та
позашкільні заклади центру розвитку тощо
А до нас входять різні формати шкіл
починаючи від невеличких там на 10-20
дітей і закінчуючи велике від школи по
тисячі дітей і відповідно а також
мережах в тому числі міжнародній мережі
і відповідно це дозволяє бачити
комплексне питання бачити комплексне
рішення
і бачите комплексно розвиток галузі
негайні питання які є на сьогодні Це
звісно фінансування
це
підготовка перепідготовка кадрів
Це допомога
батькам які по суті є клієнтами
приватної освіти але наразі зважаючими
військовий стан військової діями Багато
з них Поїхали за кордон А ті хто
залишились в Україні а в них дуже багато
продовження
освіти далі до різних форматів а також
ну взагалі як далі працювати
[музика]
знову ж часового переміщення не особами
або наразі їх більшість якраз
специфігіонах але
фінансовий стан Ну скажімо так не
задовільний для більшого тому дуже
важливими тут є програма державної
підтримки але потрібно розуміти що
приватна освіта це галузь яка може не
просто розвиватися сама А в ній досить
сильна конкуренція
і саме конкуренція штовхає розвиток є
двигуном розвитку приватної освіти а
відповідно
приватна освіта не просять грошей чи
чогось ще якоїсь допомоги від держави
приватна освіта хочу бути партнером
держави у розвитку і відповідно
робити спільні дії які допоможуть
державі в тому числі адже Кожен учень
який навчається в приватній освіті
полегшує навантаження на Державний
бюджет
бо держава його майже не фінансує або не
фінансує взагалі
відповідно що більше розвивається
приватна освіта то менше навантаженнями
державні бюджети сьогодні будуть нашого
учасники будуть говорити про різні
форми про різні напрямки
розвитку співпраці взаємодії
я зупинюсь на ключові перше потрібні
новий формати співпраці з
друге обов'язково потрібно розвиток
державного приватного партнерства
зокрема корпоративних закладів освіти
якщо в нас є в
законі а третє потрібно щось вирішувати
з орендою комунального майна в
приватнена школами після даних
а далі обов'язково потрібно реформувати
систему підготовки кадрів педагогів
вихователів Для навчальних закладів
особливо приватної освіти по вимоги
набагато більше
ніж в державній освіті
ну і звісно потрібно допомагати батькам
А через механізми
субвенції в школах і через механізми
програми Гроші входять за дитиною яку
потрібно реалізовувати максимально як
дошкільний
навчальних тому що
держава з одного боку гарантує
з іншого боку
на сьогодні держава не може навіть не
повинна забезпечити повністю безкоштовну
освіту для
приватний закладах держава може просто
компенсувати свої зобов'язання через год
механізм компенсації гроші ходять до
дитини
ною це буде правильно і це буде
стимулювати
до розвитку а відповідно буде
[музика]
економ тому
приватна освіта на сьогодні
важливість цієї галузі стала набагато
актуальнішою ніж було раніше і тому
зараз От такі секція і всі наші теми
будуть присвяченими саме цьому питанню
бізнес-асоціація освітніх закладів
розвивається вже два роки за ці два роки
ми вирости до 300 учасників кожного року
до нас приєднуються в середньому 100 200
учасників нових тому що це дуже
актуальне тому що в нас асоціації всі
відчувають себе
справжній командою
взаємодопомогою взаємопідтримкою і
універсальним інструментами для
вирішення будь-яких питань освітнього
закладу
І власне Сьогодні ми можемо також
Сказати що
[музика]
асоціація буде
транспортуватись з Нового року ми
плануємо вже отримати всеукраїнський
статус тобто стати всеукраїнською
асоціацію освітніх проектів бо на
сьогодні ми вже об'єднуємо 19 областей
місць а також ми запускаємо напрямок
міжнародної співпраці нам дуже цікаво
співпрацювати з міжнародними асоціаціями
а також
закладами освіти приватної освіти в
інших країнах тому Запрошуємо до
співпраці і дуже
раді взаємність співпраці ми зі свого
боку завжди відкритий до будь-яких
пропозицій побажань і
обміну обміну досвідом обміну
спеціалістами практики
інших насправді досвід українського
освіти особливо останніх місяців
унікальний
по я можу сказати що ми сьогодні у нас в
асоціації 98% учасників відновили свою
в офлайн тобто працюють і сади і школи і
центр розвитку компанії
з дітьми допомагають надають знижки
суттєві спеціальні умови для
пільгових категорій для переміщених осіб
для дітей
ЗСУ тріо і такий інше А унікальний
досвід взагалі
волонтерської діяльності за період
військових дій ми допомогли більше 10
батьків сімей дітей
в різних сферах починаючи від евакуації
з гарячих точок розміщення годування
логістики
закінчуючи психологічною реабілітацію та
реабілітацію взагалі Ну і власне освітою
аби перших хто створили
ще
в останні дні лютого
створили онлайн
безкоштовні онлайн
платформи для освіти дітей а І власне У
нас багато закладів які запустили із вже
на початку березня в тому числі в офлайн
для
більшого більше Здебільшого для
підтримки та реабілітації
дітей батьків ніж для навчання і тому
зараз вже і навчальні заходили тому що
є контакт як говориться
А це загалом про асоціацію А тепер
передаю слово наступному виступаючому
Олена пані Олена
голова асоціації а керівників навчальних
закладів України будь ласка наша колега
з державного університету
[оплески]
Доброго дня шановні колеги
рада вітати вас я Олена Миколаївна онець
Президент асоціації керівників шкіл
України яка створена в 93-му році і з
того ж 93-го року є асоційованим членом
Європейської Асоціації керівників шкіл
Тобто чому асоційований Тому що в нас не
на нас напряму не поширюється проекти
європейських країн і Ради Європи і так
далі Євросоюзу Зрозуміло Але ми тісно
співпрацюємо і Андрій принесла
подарунок книжечку яку ми ще з
баладської асоціацією
підготували книга і базовий стандарт
професійної діяльності керівника ще в
2003 році і нову програму підвищення
кваліфікації і навчання До речі саме з
нашого проекту розпочалася
магістерська підготовка керівник
навчального закладу хочу сказати що це
наша заслуга зараз я екс-директор школи
Київської 41-ї
працювала в 41-й школі з бібліотекаря до
директора і зараз я завідувач відео
економіки управління загальної середньої
освіти
науково-дослідний інституту ми
педагогіки Національної академії
педагогічних наук інституту який
займається проблематикою
загальних дошкільних займаються відносно
Інститут проблем виховання ВХ Ну і
обдарованими дітьми в нас є інститутом
обдарованої дитини є ще 12
націона
льних у нашій відділ займається
фундаментальними дослідженнями питань
управління загальної середньої освіти і
конкретних заклади мов освіти і зараз
зокрема ну завершили ми управління
закладом освіти як активною відкритими
соціально-еколічними системами А зараз
ще рік у нас
продовжуються фундаментальне дослідження
державна громадське управління закладами
загальної середньої освіти на засадах
партнерської
взаємодії які передбачаються що ця
взаємодія має бути суб’єктною тому буде
результатом монографія практичний
посібник і методичні рекомендації один
із практичних посібників про
громадсько-активні школи з попереднього
дослідження є в Андрія значить все це
можна знайти на сайті інституту
педагогіки електронна бібліотека там є
рубрика там є вся продукція інституту і
електронна бібліотека Національної
академії педагогічних на
ук це зрозуміло ну працюючи в школі це
не то що в нас закінчили зараз у нас є
аспірантура ще в інституті як захистила
дисертацію тому ми залишилися без роботи
коли вирішила піти уже зі школи і то а
зараз уже Я не просто провідний науковий
співробітник а завідувач відділу бо
управлінців на превеликий жаль мало тому
тема сьогоднішньої звучить так що
державна приватна партнерство в
управління закладами загальної середньої
освіти Але ж ви ж розумієте що дошкільні
заклади чи позашкільні чи будь-які інші
і мають багато спільного і багато мають
багато спільного і державні і приватні
тому я вітаю вашу асоціацію
вважаючи як новостворену організацію і
знаєте відзначила те чого ми не могли
робити у вас передбачено те що Костя ваш
адвокат це те що у вас юридичний су всі
вашій діяльності нарешті забезпечена і
це повірте мені ми не могли собі цього
дозволи
ти вирішувати питання як мій а все-таки
це питання дуже на необхідно бо
соціальний захист це дуже важливо ну ви
ж пам'ятаєте гоніння на директорів шкіл
все там всякі різні вони
[музика]
вже Ніхто з них не повернувся бо вже Ну
така така ситуація Отже державна
приватне партнерство в зв'язку з нашою
темою державна громадське управління
коли ми могли Перепрошую занурилися саме
в державну приватне партнерство
називається зараз цей термін вже
публічно приватне
партнер і передбачає не тільки співпрацю
держави і приватного сектора аніж
секторального взаємодію між приватним
сектором громадськістю і державного і
бізнесом
є зрозуміло агітувати за це не треба бо
модернізацію освіти Від цього залежить
успіхи майбутньої України Від цього
залежить Хочу наголосити що
державна
приватна державна приватне партнерство
відображено в законі України статті 6
серед принципів і окрема стаття є про це
є окремий закон про державного
приватного партнерства і в усіх
документах які вже потім з'являлися там
це все передбачається і дуже цікавий
документ - це
цілі тисячоліття до 30-го року і
програма ця економічного розвитку до
30-го року крім того що вже теж
зроблено ще ви знаєте що з військо
воєнним станом розроблена є вже програма
дій в нашій країні і там 12 і ще якісь
пункти напряму світу Я б хотіла Можливо
ще не ознайомилися з ними значить
основне інновації компетентності такий в
нас перше я ще не зовсім розумію що таке
створення чи модернізація в Коломацьких
шкіл Ну були опорні школи саме
дослідження проводили А що тепер
флагманській школи пока не знаю І як це
зробити
по-друге значить підвищення якості шкіл
які відстоюють А хто це визначив на
підставі чого будуть називатися школи
які відстають Третє - це перенавчання
вчителів і насамперед ротація кадрів там
художниця мало того що і так дехто
залишиться без роботи і проблеми в
зв'язку з тим що вони всі діти
повернулися за кордоном і так далі Ну і
в світ
інновації в закладі освіти тобто не може
працювати освіта зрозуміла без науки без
педагогічної науки хоча педагогічна
наука виникає саме з практики насамперед
Це я вам кажу і як практи
ки і як нараховується Отже це дуже
коротко
такі моменти значить з'явився цей термін
наскільки я вам хочу у 80-х роках
лідером є Великобританія але я читала
дуже цікавий досвід ми досліджували Тому
це буде описано в наших фракціях ви
зможете потім познайомитися
вот
ми співпрацюємо відділ оскільки Я
поєдную поки що дві посади то Зрозуміло
що все все що ми не робимо ми з
комітетом Верховної Ради з ядом членом
громадської ради державної служби якості
освіти в Україні заступник голови
посередньої освіти Ну і так далі ми
співпрацюємо з усіма
організаціями інстанціями і скрізь де
можемо ми скрізь відстоюємо інтереси і
буквально
недавно глянула додаток до листа якогось
Міністерства я не знаю яку до чого але
положення про
корпоративні заклади значить директор
домінант інфінітіла Світлана Василівна
підніма запитання ми розглядалися на
робочій комісії у комітеті Верховної
Ради бо я весь час саме тих робочих
комісіях ще буває так що можете якусь
інформацію мені передавала То якраз
розглядалося це питання і депутати там
тобто в тому числі Гришина підтримувала
це так що ми можемо це робити
Якщо говорити про державну
превосток є такі два документи Європа
користується
принцип розроблено комітетом знову
київ-технологічної політики організації
економічного співробітництва і розвитку
і у нас є в законі Ну там виставили
просто коротко написано що вони
рівноправні самі собою зрозуміло що
дотримується всіх норм правої
нормативної генетичних якихось А у нас
все-таки держава себе убезпечує що
по-перше конкурсне визначення приватних
партнерів і діяльність має бути така
спільна діяльність має більше бути більш
ефективною ніж діяльність просто
приватного закладу освіти новорівність
інтересів і незмінність
дії думки якщо вже він підписаний ну про
форми
про все це говорити я вам пропоную
відділ ще уже
технології бізнесу які ми адаптували до
умов освіти і вже їх описали це і не
кажу вже про бренд стратегії і
тимбілдинг і
інжинірингініринг А аутсорсинг і
Кроуфорд який краусовці і багато інших
чисто
управлінські це однозначно це проектний
такий технопарки це інноваційний
аутсор це функціональний а от те що
фандрейзинг - це акумуляція зовнішніх
ресурсів я вже закінчу це функціональний
Контрик із ресурсний Форсайт управлінців
управлінський концепції мережі
управління ми цим з вами вже
користуємося
маркетизація
костюмеризм Ну і так далі ми готові В
цьому плані працювати хочу що ніхто
спеціально не готує до державного
партнерства із 37 програм Це не я
досліджувала інші і науковці Ніде такого
конкретного немає Я так трошки
публічного управління і так далі Тобто
потрібно вносити наша пропозиція
потрібно вносити цю програму підготовки
фахівців починаючи з менеджерів які
навчаються у педагогічних вузах і не
тільки потрібно це в магістерській
програмі Ну можливо і вже потім для
підготовки докторів філософії друге ще я
пропоную конкретно це ми з вами можемо
уже зараз І ми готові відділу академії
На якому рівні по-перше запрошую вас до
нас в інститут ми можемо прямо там
зустрітися і провести якісь захід вони
завтра 250 осіб є конференц взяли в
академії там ця техніка те що треба і
друге ми можемо проводити для того щоб і
рекламувати і свою діяльність і
поширювати кращі практики бо теоретично
то те щось написано
можна правда більше на міждержавну на
загальнодержавному рівні проблеми
повірте мені дуже багато на місцях на
місцях Тому може проводитись семінари
вебінари ми готові до співпраці і
асоціація і відділ економіки управління
і взагалі всі відділи предметні
навчальні бо в нас підручники зараз до
речі відбувається літня школа по Пізі
для вчителів і умовно-літературної і
природничої галузі і математики
півмісяць от зараз у нас відбувається
навчання інституті в нас є такі курси
так що Давно Ми вже вийшли з того стану
що
дати так завжди скептично ставилися до
академії педагогічних Науки до її
інституцій повірте мені як практику
Знаєте як я вже я ж українка поки саме
не перевірити я і не переконався то я
нікому не ходив бажаю Нам усім спільного
успіху і вірю в те що ми разом досягнемо
кращих результатів Дякую за увагу
наступного учасника асоціації це Галина
шоста
голова першої школи освітнього бізнесу і
співзасновник
фізико-математичної школи кібєта а також
мережі дитячого закладів Американ
Добрий день всім
Рада сьогодні буде тут я Галина Шостак
ми з вами вже багато з ким знайомі я уже
9-й рік
приватній освіті і насправді знаєте отак
от аналізуючи весь цей досвід вже 9-й
рік я спостерігаю за тим як приватна
освіта в Україні поступово поступово з
такого зародку розвивається розвивається
розширюється наших закладів в Україні
стає все більше стає все більше шкіл в
садочків конкуренція зростає і на
сьогоднішній момент Уже навіть тільки в
асоціацію вже 300 + закладів а в Україні
все більше і більше приват шлях освітніх
закладів тобто на сьогоднішній момент
можна стверджувати що приватна освіта з
кожним роком стає все більше і більше
таким ґрунтовним гравцем на ринку освіти
і я не побоююсь цього слова коли скажу
що приватна освіта є якраз рушієм
розвитку взагалі освіти в Україні і
Сьогодні мій виступ він присвячений саме
стратегічному партнерства між державою і
приватними закладами На мою думку зараз
якщо озираючись назад ми бачимо останні
три роки взагалі для освітніх закладів
бути дуже важкі починаючи з коронавірусу
продовжуючи війною і насправді багато
закладів вчилися
існувати в Нових реаліях багато
власників таких знаєте про активних Я
просто захоплююсь насправді власником
освітніх закладів в Україні і їм нічого
не страшно будь-яка будь-я є проблема
яка існує створюється в Україні в світі
вони і знаєте спочатку що робити що
робити а потім ідуть голубій вирішують і
далі продовжують надавати якісні послуги
от тільки подивитися продовжуючи те що
сказав Андрій Близнюк що
освітні заклади почали працювати навіть
офлайн уже з березня цього року тобто на
сьогоднішній момент Це ці заклади які
прямо зацікавлені в тому щоб освіта
розвивалась щоб вона ставала якіснішою і
я вам хочу сказати як людина яка працює
з великою кількістю власних і в освітніх
закладів це дуже ціннісні люди які
щиро зацікавлені в тому щоб розвивати не
тільки свій освітній заклад але і освіту
в Україні в цілому і сьогодні я вийшла з
пропозицією і підтримую промову Андрія
Близнюка щодо того що ми маємо стати
стратегі бачимо партнерами з державами
на сьогодні момент перед нами стоїть
дуже велика і така
я би сказала ціннісна задача не тільки
відновити Україну після війни але і
повернути людей які ви а це молоді мами
з дітьми Якраз ті які цікавлять нас Як
освітян тих людей які виїхали з-за
кордону і уже деякі з них з них пробують
влаштувати своє життя там тобто Наша
задача зараз не тільки просто відновити
навчальні заклади а Наша задача створити
таку систему освіти тобто змінити так
всю систему з урахуванням того що є
зараз на часі щоб і
відбудувати економіку щоб створити
приклад якісної освіти яка може бути
прикладом насправді для всього світу і
ми як приватні освітні заклади готові
включитися до роботи у нас дуже така от
стійка цінністьна асоціація ми справжня
команда яка готова до роботи і багато
чого ми можемо робити
тільки на своєму ентузіазмі тому що ми
сильно зацікавлені в цьому розвитку від
вас ми просимо розглянути варіант ми
бачимо вже насправді за ці 9 років от як
я спостерігаю за цим так от уважно і
насправді відкриваю і маю різні
форми освіти від дитячих центрів
дитячого садочків школи
там школа тобто я практично дотична до
багатьох форм освіти і може сказати що
на сьогоднішній момент
ми
держава
так чи інакше допомагає у світі
розвиватися тобто ми уже бачимо
позитивний вплив на освіту на приватну
зі сторони держави це і те що насправді
і ця конференція Так ви б запрошуєте нас
до участі ви запрошуєте до нас до
обговорення законопроектів різних норм і
так далі це теж нам дуже нами дуже
цінуються і ми це бачимо також
спрощені були ліцензійні умови
впроваджені принаймні в Києві такі
поняття як
гроші входять за дитиною різні програми
тому шкільних способинцій і так далі
Тобто це все кожна ця крапля вона
практично допомагає нам зростати а тим
самим ми дійсно зменшуємо навантаження і
на державний сектор освіти так і ми
допомагаємо
цьому світі в цілому розвиватися надалі
Ми хочемо поглибити це партнерство Ми
хочемо вийти на рівень того що ми з вами
є повноцінними партнерами Тобто ми чуємо
вас і ми зацікавлені в розвитку освіти в
Україні Ви чуєте нас бо ви теж
зацікавлені в розвитку освіти в Україні
Якщо ми будемо матч мати
спільну стратегічну мету А я вважаю що
ми насправді її маємо і просто треба
окреслити і прийняти знаєте як за
правило що ми це будемо робити і всі
інші інструменти які вже обговорені були
Андрій почав говорити і зараз моєї
колеги партнери будуть далі продовжувати
говорити про різні варіанти співпраці
але кожен із цих варіантів він іде з
фундаментального усвідомлення що
держава є стратегічним партнером
приватної освіти і я можу сказати
всього від всіх насправді
власників приватних освітніх приватних
закладів в Україні що ми готові до
роботи з вами ми готові розробляти
нормативні документи ми готові їх
впроваджувати ми у нас до закладах
зазвичай відсутня бюрократія Тобто ми
достатньо швидко можемо змінювати якісь
якісь правила впроваджувати
експериментувати у нас це все достатньо
швидко робиться І ми готові цим ділитися
ми готові це впроваджувати і готові
допомагати і навіть не те що допомагати
а брати активну участь в державою для
відбудови України і для формування
освіти надалі що ми пропонуємо ми
пропонуємо
в першу чергу давайте ще Так що ми
потребуємо ми зараз бачимо що насправді
Якщо говорити про розвиток освіти то
кожен із нас на своєму рівні свої
освітні заклади розвиває і
здебільшого ми всі розвивалися свої
заклади не зважаючи на державну ми
просто брали норми ми їх виконували і
далі І далі діяли так як нам треба було
діяти для того щоб
бізнес працював для того щоб ми надавала
якісну освіту і так далі на сьогоднішній
момент на мої думки ми маємо створити
такі умови щоб
тому було працювати легше бо буде
працювати легше нам буде значно легше і
краще держать тому що ми потребуємо ми
потребуємо
участь в прийнятті нормативних актів Ми
потребуємо бути повноцінним партнером і
давати свої рекомендації і ми хочемо щоб
з нашою думкою рахувались тому що ми є
партнерами Так ми потребуємо змін щодо
деяких врегульованих і недостатньо
врегульованих питань таких як
корпоративні школи таких як оренда
державної власності для відкриття
приватних закладів Ми потребуємо більш
детального
розписаного фінансування освітніх
закладів і розповсюдженням Таких програм
як гроші ходять за дитиною таких як
шкільна субвенція І взагалі от такі от
базові нормативи які гроші які ходять за
дитиною освітні заклади ми можемо
забезпечити
освіту і відкривати освітні заклади у
нас достатня кількість людей яких хочуть
розвиватися в приватному світі і для
цього для того щоб це все було ефективно
для того щоб ми могли це робити в умовах
фінансової нестабільності Нам потрібні і
умови відповідні умови по оренті
відповідні умови по комунальних послуг
тому що ви напевно знаєте що комунальні
послуги декілька разів зросли Минулого
року це дійсно суттєво вплинуло на
діяльність освітніх закладів Нам
потрібні нам потрібно допомога в
фінансуванню фінансування якщо вона
можлива так І звісно в закладах якісь
співпраці між державою і приватними
закладами щодо наприклад державного
замовлення якщо ми навіть вирішимо з
вами от оці базові питання То я бачу що
приватний заклад приватна освіта
приватний приватний сектор буде розви
навчалася іще стрімкіше і
достатньо сильно зменшити навантаження і
на державний сектор і тим більше в такій
короткій перспективі вирішить питання з
великою кількістю наприклад переселенців
І а натомість зруйновані заклади ви
знаєте державні заклади зруйновані і є
місця де діти не можуть навчатися тому
приватні заклади швидше може це питання
вирішити і вже ви знаєте всі працюють
тому будь ласка завершуючи мій виступ
хочу сказати що ми готові до співпраці
ми готові стати повноцінним рівноцінним
стратегічним партнером держави ми можемо
і хочемо зробити все для того щоб ми з
вами разом йшли до єдиної стратегічної
мови Дякую
Дякуємо Галя
наступний учасник виступаючий учасник
асоціації Володимир стаєнський а
засновник мережі
шкіл ліцею конверта яка працює як в
Україні
Штатах Америки А має великий досвід в
тому числі міжнародних чартерних школи
державна приватного партнерства от йому
і слово з цієї теми
Доброго дня
Доброго дня всім Вітаю на практичній
раді посвяченій відкриттів нового
навчального року 2022
в мене
почесне завдання пояснити що таке
корпоративні школи яка за які зараз
засади є і що
це може принести дітям батькам освітянам
кропиви школа
вперше була
[музика]
з першою де поліція за з'явилося в
законі України про повну загальну
середню освіту і дехниця дуже проста і
коробка корпоративний заклад це
засновник заклад заснований шляхом
укладення засновницького договору
кількома засновниками різних форм
власності на засадах державного
приватного партнерства це стаття 31 5
розділу
далі йде лише одне уточнення що щодо
корпоративних шкіл це засновники і
корпоративного закладу
укладають засновницький договір про
утворення закладу і його структурованих
підрозділів засновницький добре має
місце цю інформацію про засновники права
обов'язки особливості управління
закладом і
е-е декілька інших
центрів стаття 33-го розділу п'ятого
це все щоб стосується за
дефініції корпоративна школа в далі в
тексті закону корпоративні заклади
освіти повністю прирівнюється в правах
та обов'язках до приватних закладів
освіти тобто функціонування регулювання
діяльності здійснюється тотожно до
приватного закладів
це дуже
притикається з
Міжнародним практикою
дівчатами шкіл часто на шкірі існують
більше ніж у 30 країнах світу в кожній
країні є особливості
притаманні саме цій країні які досвіду
та
особливості відносин в громаді між
батьками та соціальними та державою але
узагальнюючі дівчата на школа - це школа
яка отримає державну фінансування але
дії незалежні від встановлених державних
шкільній системі в якій вона знаходиться
працює вона також на підставі часто або
контракту тобто в чаті військових
корпоративні школи це також він поняття
але далі я використовую на дефініцію яка
потрібна школа
друге
блог законодавства що регулює книжної
школи Це
закон України про державне приватне
партнерство
якщо подивитися на статті номер стаття 4
розділу першого то державна приватна
партнерство застосовується у таких
сферах
першим не треба здивуватися це
інфраструктура дороги постачання тепла
розподіл постачання газу таке інше і в
тому числі передбачено що
державна приватна партнерство
застосовується в сфері надання освітніх
послуг та послуг у сфері охорони
здоров'я це другий пілагр що означає
правові засади героїв роботи
корпоративних шкіл в Україні
на засадах державного приватного
виробництва
і
якщо запитати Скільки зараз відкрито
корпоративну шкіру і яка практика
використання цього законодавства це поки
що нуль але це той шлях який вже
дуже добре себе зарекомендував в країнах
західного світу як
[музика]
Сполучених Штатах Америки Канада те що
ми любимо Фінляндія та інших країн
державне приватне партнерство - це
новація в сірі освіти для України на і
так і ні якщо
повернутися до кожного з нас Кожний з
нас є має досвід
державних програмного партнерства якщо
казати про історію нашої компанії тобто
був Просто було літо 2008 року Якраз
після
чергового кризису що був навесні 2008
року коли все в бізнесі впало а воно
починали наш бізнес і
моя партнерка дружина Оксана вперше
почала спілкування з
позичними освіти і вона почала дуже
природно з
[музика]
державного центру позашкільної освіти в
місті Києві Напевно ви всі знаєте це
окрема будівля на кловському спутській
спуску
з наявним директором Ткачук Володимир
віталійовича саме завдяки тому що цей
державний центр був зацікавлений в
оновленні в
програму освіти в інноваціях саме то
тому в цьому школі в цьому центрі вперше
з'явилось розвиток в Україні робота
техніка навчання роботи техніки в
Україні з якими літом 2008 року як
впевнений Кожний з вас є має приклади
таку подібного але або
не подібного досвіду співпраці з
державними органами
що означає корпоративна школа для нас
для підприємців правоосвітній галузі
спершу це
приходить Наум що це підвищиться
конкуренція і це так коли будуть більш
[музика]
інституції які працюють на засадах
приватних То це означає що конкуренція
буде більшою
це повинно з першого боку лякати нас але
я впевнений що
більшість
розмірковує не
ідеями конкуренція ідейний кластер
коли буде більше ринок за рахунок в тому
числі кластера дозволені мені це назвати
освітній навчальний клас про в Україні
то це надасть нам багато більше
можливості кожного з нас а за рахунок
Так це буде конкуренція що працювати на
дітей на батьків на громаду на державу в
деякій милі носітян і проти підприємців
але на підприємців це буде працювати в
іншому боці тому що
в цілому ринок стане більше в цілому
більше дітей будуть залучені до якісної
освіти більш динамічної та а
клієнтообрінтовний це означає що ми
зможемо
навчити більше вчителів крім методиками
цим знанням які ми вважаємо як на
сьогоднішній момент більш падіння тому
що з точки зору
стратегічного розвитку то корпоративні
школи - це це великоблага для приватного
світу тому що це
кратно
збільшує ринок ринок в тому числі для
нас
це для мене є аналогією того що зараз Ми
є
учасниками та свідками цього
тектонічного звіту Коли Україна приєднає
приєднується до Європейського союзу з
точки зору підприємців це повинна лякати
нас тому що ми отримаємо після
основні кордону як ми отримуємо більше
конкуренцій і зараз ми бачимо дуже
багато
англомовних шкіл на в нашому просторі
дуже багато онлайн на світі і це є
конференція для нас але
підсвідома або свідомо ми знаємо що
приєднання до
сучасних більш динамічних і
цивілізованих формах ведення бізнесу це
надає для кожного з нас набагато більше
можливості і навіть якщо це потребує від
нас більше енергії конференції Петра
інвестицій
для
повертаючись корпоративним в школу на
сьогоднішній момент в Україні 0
корпоративної школи
незважаючи на дуже підготовлену
законодавчу базу а ще відсутнє
нормативна документація що дозволяє
практично створити корпорати
вний А на наше щастя Ми маємо дуже
чуттєвих і дуже
свідомих партнерів в
особах представників Міністерства освіти
і науки які вже погодили вже прийняли
[музика]
доцільність до опрацювання законодавства
на рівні Міністерства освіти і на рівні
Кабінету Міністрів і вже Ми домовились
що ця робота в форматі робочих групи
запасних Міністерства освіти і з
представників
нашої асоціації буде створена і на
протязі дуже стислого періоду часу 2-3
місяці ми можемо напрацювати всі на
необхідно проекти документів які
дозволить в подальшому
по цій
реалізувати ці практики наприклад на
шкірі
Це дуже
гарно новина як на нас тому що дуже
зрозуміло що потрібно Зрозуміло Як це
зробити залишилося одна річ це зробити
це Але це вже кипіла зроблена її
організовано
дякую
Володя
наступний учасник асоціації
по суті навіть не учасник а
співзасновник
наш юрист адвокат координатора асоціації
Костя Падалка
асоціації
вам слово що вимагаємо з питань і
проблема раз раз
друзі ну по-перше ще раз вітаю вас
з тим що ми сьогодні спільно проводимо
із такий захід
дуже багато цікавих питань сьогодні
приймає участь у програмному засіданні
власне життя
перша половина дня
дуже багато новин все це будемо писати в
чаті асоціації
на жаль дуже мало було часу на те щоб
розповісти наші актуальні питання тому
буду зараз з вами все проговорювати А ви
мені киваєте якщо я виглядав на
актуальними питаннями власне
Тема моєї умовною доповіді сьогодні це
фінансовий аспект Ну можна назвати це
аспектором можна називати проблемими
ситуаціями Але мені здається що для всіх
вас в момент абсолютно знайомі
фінансування і його недостатність якщо
ми говоримо про державні заходи
комунальні зрозуміло що все це
фінансується за рахунок бюджету що ми
говоримо про корпоративні або перевертні
заклади про корпоративні вже трохи
сьогодні Говорили ми говоримо про те що
вам потрібно десь знаходити фінансування
І власне зазвичай ці джерела
фінансування - Це ваші власні
надходження
при цьому ситуація ускладнюється тим що
є
ряд зовнішніх факторів які вам заважають
працювати заважають власне інвестувати в
подальшому ваш бізнес і надають
можливості розвиватися
номер один проблема можна навіть назвати
на ситуацію саме проблемою яка зараз
існує це проблема комунальних тарифів Я
думаю що
99% всієї проблеми стикалися і це
проблема У нас звичайно на перший рік
але минулої зими всі отримали платіжні
доручення в яких суми були 2 3 4 5 6 і
навіть 10 разів більше ніж це було
раніше і звичайно за таких обставин
якось спланувати тому що добувати свій
бізнес ну фактично не може бути
якогось єдиного рішення в цій ситуації
на даний час не існує але ми говоримо
про те що є механізмом в державі які
встановлять Для певних суб’єктів
господарів просто суб'єктів навіть на
підприємствах тарифи які є меншими йшли
що встановлені для звичайного конкурсу
моя ідея полягає в тому щоб встановити
законодавчу закріпити норму
підлягають перебуванню так само як
релігійні організації власне це може
бути новим брендом який так можна
називати що освіта - це наша нова лінія
ну по-перше звучить непогано досить а
по-друге реально дозволяє вирішити
питання того як саме вам в подальшому
можна сплачувати відповідаючи на питання
кого це може стосуватися Звичайно що це
буде стосуватися виключно закладів
освіти дуже важко буде цю норму
застосувати до клубів центрів тобто
неліцензованих заходів єдиним варіантом
коли це можна буде зробити для
неліцензійних це власне заклади позначки
на освіту тобто знову ж таки заклади
освіти не ліцензійні але все ж таки
освіт
це той варіант який я бачу собі бачу
собі основним для цілей завдання
асоціації для того щоб ми проробляли цей
варіант з державного органами займалася
легальним лобіюванням цієї ситуації і
власне ваша підтримка в соціальних
мережах серед батьків
державних органів
це тому що ті тарифи на
енергопостачання які були Минулого року
в минулому і земельні ті що будуть зараз
ви знову ж таки скорочуєте різницю і це
питання треба вирішувати просто
терміново
погоджуєтесь
прекрасно
це питання номер один питання номер два
державна підтримка з того що я починав
зараз вся
фінансування здійснюється за ваш рахунок
при цьому існують в деяких містах
підтримка для закладів дошкільної освіти
це власне на зараз місто Київ та Львів
де запроваджені часткова програма Гроші
входять за дитиною для заходу дошкільної
освіти і є освітньо субвенція для
батьків
Справа в тому що і стосовно субвенції і
стосовно за дитиною позитивні моменти
так і негативні є певно непрозорість в
калькуляції завжди до мене виникають як
то адвоката освітнього питання стосовно
як прорахувати як отримати і так далі
і це не єдина проблема те що відсутня
проблем такої що охоплює всі приватні
заклади освіти а насправді кожен
приватний заклад освіти будь то садочок
будь ласка школа неї навіть позашкільні
заклади вони фактично забирають до себе
частину дітей які мали б ходити до
державного закладу освіти отримувати
гарантовану державу безоплатне право
але витрачаєте на це ви та батьки
при цьому постійно збільшується вимоги
до матеріальної технічної
бази всі пам'ятають про вимоги під час
карантину тобто я аспекти на
яких мали витрачати додаткові кошти
все покладалося виключно на вас при
цьому гроші ходять за дитиною є наразі
проблеми в місті Києві я заборгованість
спочатку цього року при тому що вони
нараховуються вони обліковуються в
казначействі проте є нормативні акти які
по факту забороняють нам здійснити
виплату ви ці кошти не отримали
є питання субвенцію є дуже багато
чинників та
людей посадовців які хочуть впливати на
цей процес на калькуляцію того як має
визначатися освітній ситуації є різні
точки зору є точки зору яку говорить про
те що треба збільшувати підтримку є
точки зору який говорить про те що
приватні заклади мають фінансувати себе
все ж таки самостійно що у вас є клієнти
і нехай клієнти сплачують але
економічна ситуація в країні така що в
будь-якому випадку ми не можемо навіть
їх би хотіли перекласти все це на ваших
клієнтів тому що на них це економічна
ситуація також впливає і тому задача
номер два стосовно нашої діяльності
якості
[музика]
запровадження такої державної підтримки
централізованої якості освітньої
субвенції яка буде поширена на
всіх або альтерна
тивних і централізовано за принципом
який реалізуються в місті Києві можливо
із вдосконаленням але тепер розуміємо
тільки на заклад дошкільної освітить але
і на заклади середньої перспективі і на
позовщині тому що вони насправді нічні
не гірше і вони реально допомагають
дітям здобувати ту освіту який вона яку
вона не може здобувати в школі або в
садочку я дуже багато прикладів і буде
це фактично заміна класичної школи але
при цьому дитина
займається за сімейним фоном приблизно
так відповідно друге питання - це
державна підтримка
третє питання яке Також болюче ми його
обговорювали в рамках діяльності
асоціації це кредитування ну знову ж
таки я люблю проводити міні-опити Хтось
взагалі пробував отримувати кредит у нас
на заклад освіти
ну це насправді дуже вдала історія що
вдалося тому що
Приват
моя статистика говорить про те що
приблизно із 30 спроб приблизно однак і
при цьому не знаю як у вас було але
зазвичай вдала спроба поєднується вже з
існуючою нерухомістю або з паралельним
бізнесом який фактично виступає
заставить датися тобто на суто освітній
бізнес Ну майже неможливо отримати або
умови які видаються вони на неї не є
досить адекватними в тому що існують
програми спільно з європейськими
інвестиційним банком який передбачають
кредитування малого та середнього
бізнесу в Україні на це виділяється
кошти при цьому чомусь досі жодним із
закладів освіти брати в цією програ
кредит не отримав хоча власне ми як
освіта і є тим самим малим і середнім
візусом У мене є великому бізнесом як
однакова не хотілося значення економічно
для держави саме малий і середній навіть
іноді мікробізнес і відповідно все це
кредитування ті Кошти які перераховує
Європейський союз вони можуть бути
призначені для вас проте чим це
ускладнюється тим що будь-якому випадку
приймає рішення щодо надання кредиту
конкретний банк і банку звичайно
простіше видати кредит агропідприємство
чи підприємство торгівлі там де є Щось
ще можна помацати у нас послуг більше
того послуга освітня яка погана
прораховується не є надприбутковою і
можна зрозуміти банкірів коли вони
кажуть Ні
тому виходом із цієї ситуації на мою
думку є запровадження конкретної
програми для закладів освіти це може
бути пільгова кредитування це може бути
програма 5-79 це можуть бути програми в
рамках тих програм що за провезення
європейського інвестиційним банком
спільно з нашого банками але конкретно
виділений по освіті
значно опитувань те що я пам'ятаю
приблизно умовних 300 учасників на той
момент
15% сказали про те що їм такі програми
кредитування цікаві ми знову ж таки на
той момент із тих з ким м'ясних
поспілкуватися Раніше у всіх були спроби
і не було нікого якраз успішної спроби
отримання кредиту відповідно одна з
наступних цілей саме при взаємодії з
державою це визначення разом з державою
Таких програм які будуть визначати
пільгове кредитування для закладів
освіти
наступне питання приміщення
воно пов'язано в принципі з питань
державного приватного партнерства але
більш класичними більш знайомим на даний
час механізмом того щоб отримати якісь
адекватне велике приміщення з території
є оренда державного боку комунального
майна незважаючи на те що на даний час
дуже багато насправді зроблено держави в
плані полегшення та спрощення процедур
оренди немає як такої процедури окремої
для закладів освіти і нам відповідно
доводиться конкурувати з підприємствами
інших секторів економіки навіть в
приміщення які за своїм цільовим
призначенням часто призначено саме під
освітньої діяльності тобто буде велася
як школа або садочки або в подальшому
були перебудовані або ще таке часто
ситуація коли вони початково
призначалися а потім стали житловим
будинком все одно 10 проектних
документації є освітня категорія
діяльності всі ці приміщення ми
пропонуємо визначати як пріоритетні для
закладів освіти враховуючи наявну
нормативну базу тобто визначений
переліків для оренди майна ми можемо
просити про створення окремих переліків
для оренди майна і до світу і лише у
випадку якщо немає ніяких орендних на це
приміщення немає бажаючих хотіла б його
орендувати саме під освіту після трьох
років аукціону відповідно вже здавати в
загальний перегляд
це має бути максимально
відкрив відкриту такий перелік і бачите
мати можливість ознайомлюватися з
такимином І ще одне важливе питання - це
строк знову ж таки законодавство зараз
вже немає тих трьох років щоб було
раніше є вже нормам про 5 років проте
щоразу питання про визначення строку
воно залишається на визначеннях тієї
комі яка приймає рішення про проведення
власних приватизації або оренди
державного комунального
майна для нас лопненому варіантом
запроваджувати відразу мінімальні строк
такої оренди під освіту на освітні цикл
умовно це 17-19 років тобто
закладушкільної освіти плюс заклад
середньої освіти
Повний цикл відповідно ви таким чином
будете
від того що що три роки чи ще 5 років
Вам доведеться незрозуміло як проходить
непростора того що ви в своєму вже
орендованому приміщенні відбудували
побудували а зараз можна прийти ситуація
що
орендодавець це може бути районне
управління освіти районної державної
адміністрація сільська рада і так далі
говоримо про те що ми знай
шли Звичайно що за ці роки і поки ви
обслуговували це приміщення Поки ви
створювали матеріально-технічну базу
дійсно Може хтось із з'явитися
зацікавлений не тільки під освіту але й
під інші якісь проекти вже маючи
приміщення доведених в талант відповідно
наступний пріоритет наш Це питання
оренди державного та комунального майна
і спрощення для освітніх закладів і
Останній із таких головних пріоритетів
це державна приватна партнерство Я знаю
сьогодні вже про цю тему говорили як
підкреслюю що в будь-якому випадку
вважається варіант дійсно перспективним
цікавим оскільки не дозволяє отримувати
управління як майно так і заклади освіти
так і земельну ділянку під забудову
наприклад І що головне перекльовувати
індивідуальні питання стосовно того як
це все відбувається хто вкладає кошти
хто отримає Хто виходить
Тобто Це добре Так це договір з державою
але боятися цього не потрібно тому що в
тих випадках коли є в нас таких гнучкий
інструмент як договір
виступаєте у відносини з державою вже
певним чином захищений оскільки ви
розумієте що саме ми Прописали про що ми
йдемо хто говорять які саме умови там
визначено відповідно які є ось гарантії
є Які ризики але підкресліть що на даний
час
нормативно-правової бази немає є
визначення в законі про середню освіту
та про дошкільну освіту того що є
корпоративний заклад освіти засновниками
якого є якраз держава та приватним
партнер І сьогодні я озвучував це
питання і вже в нас іде спілкування з
міністерством освіти і
нормативно базу і ці питання тобто
положення про Ось такі корпоративний
заклад освіти примірні договори
механізми гарантій і так далі
і тому ось це задача номер 5 для нашої
комунікації з державою сподіваюся що всі
шановні посадовці наш нас також зможуть
почути
і ми плануємо дійсно в рамках робочої
групи яка буде діяти в прямому України
ці питання вирішувати ми власне в рамках
асоціації вже оголосили набір всіх
бажаючих всіх хто має достатньо знання
досвід і головне під час для того щоб
присвятити себе цій діяльності хоча б
частково для того щоб ми могли спільно
зусиллями якраз спільноти допомогти
державі перебудувати ринок приватної
освіти
Дякую друзі
[оплески]
як це означає
наступного учасниця асоціації Валентина
Гірняк
засновник ліцею чіджей академії з міста
Ірпінь
[музика]
що може об'єднати і Державу і приватні
заходи тому сьогодні будемо говорити
майно освітній маркетинг а саме про
бренд освітній бренд України яка цікава
річ відбулася коли почалось
повномасштабне вторгнення України в
Росію майже 5 мільйонів українців стало
більше це не в Європі
2.3 мільйони це діти Що відбулося різко
вся ця спільнота занурилася в освітній
системі щонайменше 44 країн світу що
вона побачила вона побачила ці освітні
системи зсередини що Вона показала Вона
показала сильні сторони української
освіти
якщо рухатися далі то ми зрозуміємо що
якщо ми говоримо про бренд то бренд - це
враження бренд - це історія бренд - це
сприйняття і якщо ми зараз на жаль я не
знайшла дослідження яке показало яке б
зараз було проведено але якби ви зараз
запитали європейців куди приїхали
українські діти а якими є українські
діти
що це розуміють діти діти які знають
добре математи
ку взяти добре англійську це проактивне
життєва
позиція діти які допомагають звіти всіма
своїми талантами
в цілому України
якщо рухатися далі
[музика]
ніж сприйняття Європи світу України було
більш негативним то зараз починає
з'являтися така цікава річ що Україна
вже асоціюється не тільки з корупцією і
неможливістю змінити судову систему але
й з тим що ми з цим країнам яка виборює
свою незалежність; б вона готова
рухатись на шлях демократії наступає
рухаємося до вступу в Європейський союз
якщо рухатись далі яке є сприйняття
українців це смілива нація а з іншої
сторони українці вже зараз змінили
портрет біженця в Європі Якщо порівняти
з 2015 роком коли це були свій війна в
Сирії і Якщо говорити про дітей дуже
багато і родин і освіті не говорять про
те що українські діти агрозумні і мають
унікальний набір компетенції не тільки
тверді навички але м'які навички які в
сучасному світі дуже-дуже актуальні
Що відбувається далі чому про освітній
бренд саме українське освітній бренд не
конкретної школи регіону саме цієї цієї
країни треба говорити саме зараз
діти які виїхали 44-х країнах світу
показали сильні сторони освітнього
українського продукту тобто Європа
щонайменше в Європу побачила позитивні
сторони української освіти з іншої
сторони
українські діти показали дуже цікавий
баланс саме академічних знань і м'яких
навичок життє стійкість адаптивність
гнучкість а саме ці навички будуть
ключовими через 5+ років не тільки в
Україні всьому світі і наші діти вже є
тими рольовими моделями На жаль з надто
високою ціною які вже це показують що
відбулось ще цікаве українське освітяни
почали відкривати школи вимушено за
кордоном вже показуючи або практикуючи
краще освітні практики там А це що це
вже є освітній продукт насправді з нашої
країни і останнє якщо дивитися в такому
широкому контексті освіти не тільки
школа або садочок а освіта протягом
життя то не тільки під час
війни і результат освіти насправді
як він це може успішно використати
Якщо ви хочете
відвідати освітній Точніше так відчути
бренд якоїсь країни Що ви робите ви
їдете в ту країну Якщо ви хочете відчути
гастрономічний бренд Що ви робите йдете
в той ресторан або харчування вже зараз
українські діти і українська освітянська
спільнота
показала яким може бути українською
освітній бренд от зараз вже ситуативно
сформувався бренд у бій лайк України
like ukrainians вже Вибачте китайців
роблять на цьому бізнес на наших
українців на цьому українському бренді
саме тому про українські освітній бренд
як країни цілої треба говорити Вже зараз
і не чекати Перемоги
рухаємось далі будь-який бренд можна
розглядати з чотирьох складових Ну
насправді його можна розглядати пані
світланочко можете рухатись далі з
чотирьох складових продукт тобто що може
бути
[музика]
продуктові цільової аудиторії третє як
яка може бути альдентика як він має
виглядати з ре штою і четверта це
називається бренд Sen
S яка вона історія що вірить цей день
давайте трішечки кожен блог розгля
нь якщо ми говоримо про продукт то
продукти в першу чергу я не можу зараз
[музика]
дитини Але він точно має бути комплек
сним всі рівні
осібили є дошкільна шкільна
Університетська Але ми всі забуваємо що
зараз дуже гостра потреба в навчанні
протягом всього життя Лайфу є вже дуже
хороші практики
цього навчання протягом життя тобто
український бренд має не просто
враховувати ці всі складові має
цілісно їх об'єднувати і має бути
вдячність між ними тоді як система мене
почали працювати
друге вже зараз на прикладі українських
дітей ми можемо бачити результат цього
освітнього бренду тому починати можна
якраз
[музика]
дітей якщо ми говоримо хто може бути
цільовою аудиторією Ну найпростіше це ті
хто вже зараз демонструють результат
в першу чергу це дорослі українська
it креативна соціальна спільнота яка
вносить в Європу дуже гарну динаміку і
тому з однієї сторони Коли відкриється
кордон чи боїмося ми конку комісії Ну
можливо Але мені здається що ми більше
приносимо зараз в Європу значить люди
і Бізнес ніж остров того що до нас
зайдуть в школу напевно на цьому варто
Отож це може бути вже існуючий дорослий
населення і друге - це безумовно діти
батьки молоде покоління яке розуміє що
освіта має бути інновативна в сучасна
прогресивна вони будуть шукати школу
Такі ж самі школи для своїх дітей і
останній оскільки цінова аудиторія дуже
широка для освітнього продукту Ми всі
будемо рости Ми всі будемо старіша теми
молодішати а тому контекст розглядати
освіту протягом всього життя Я вважаю що
Звичайно що треба робити точно фокус на
дані як би ми виглядати освітній бренд
відповіді Я вам не дам але з таким
сильним українським креативним сектором
як він є на сьогодні я точно впевнена що
ті освітні рішення які ми з вами не
придумали Вони точно їх реалізують перед
вами тільки кілька ключових я вважаю
і остання
бренд це про історію пам'ятаєте вам
говорила про враження про сприйняття і
ось Аліна білер зачитаю її цитату бо
вона мені дуже подобається бренд це
обіцянкам Велика ідея очікування які
містяться в свідомості кожному клієнта
щодо будинку послуги чи компанії бренд -
це встановлення емоційного
зв’язку тому Яка може бути
освітня історія України оце саме
природнє що в нас зараз є в нас
настільки кожного дня є чимало в історії
дітей
успіху не просто переборюють себе вони
ефективно навчаються в кількох школах
одночасно не забуваємо про це тому вже
зараз українські діти через їхні історії
можна створювати цей бренд тому що вони
вже зараз є творцями змін самі цього не
усвідомлюють тому друзі саме зараз час
думати над і створювати бренд України в
освітній бренд робити дослідження робити
робочу групу усвідомлювати який він має
бути дати відповіді на оці запитання щоб
після перемоги просто почати робити
Дякую
наступного нашого учасниця Кіра
стефанська засновниця ліцею юнікс клуб а
також координатор нашого методичного
центру асоціації
спеціаліст з методичною роботою будь
ласка дякую добрий день колеги
дійсно
трансформація методології освіти і ви
знаєте що приватна освіта - це сотні
експериментів сотні нових ідей сотні
нових рішень які ми дуже швидко
приймаємо пробуємо рухаємося далі і Якщо
говорити про те якою має бути далі
методологія освіти Чому ми повинні
навчати наших дітей то перше питання на
якому ми Я хотіла б
це те хто є клієнтом освіти
то дивований кодекс так часто такі
обличчя виникають освітян коли ми
говоримо слово клієнт в освіті дійсно
дуже незвично що ти це слово тому що Як
це клієнт тому що могли себе
обслуговують чи як наш навчаємо
але тут друзі Я якраз хочу звернути
увагу що клієнт - це не про ціну в
конкретному випадку це при цінність яку
Ми створюємо так тому вперше щоб трава у
собі відповідь на питання куди ми маємо
далі рухатися
потрібно визначити хто є клієнтом освіти
для кого Ми створюємо цінність в ім'я
кого ми працюємо зрештою на кого ми
працюємо так і тут Звичайно є купа
варіантів відповідей і якщо ми чесно
собі скажемо що клієнтом освіти є дитина
випускник школи
то ми далі можемо рухатися А якого
випускника школи ми маємо створити так
Це далі йде наша наступне питання
давайте ще наступний слайд
і коли ми говоримо про випускника школи
ми маємо подумати які необхідні навички
будуть йому коли він закінчить школу а
тут уже фоторологія тут уже нам потрібно
вміти прогнозувати відштовхуючись від
сучасного і рухаючись в майбутнє тому
окрім державного стандарту окрім твердих
навичок які ми даємо в наших освітніх
закладах Ми повинні дивитися на тілі
принаймні топ-10 навичок які всі
одночаснових при які ми знаємо які
озвучені на всесвітньому економічному
форумі Це ті навички які ми повинні
розвивати в кожній дитині яка навчається
в нашій школі і далі наше питання яке
яким чином розвивати кожну цю навичку
тому ми педагогічні тренди в освіті
на зараз мають бути пов'язані з тими
конкретними навичками з тими навичками
які необхідні виховати в нашому студе в
нашому учневі до завершення школи і тут
Я вам зараз наведу кілька прикладів того
що вже є в нашій освіті зокрема В моїй
школі в нашому методичному центрі це
Приклади того як ми виховуємо маємо ось
ці озвучені 10 навичок щоб вони не
виглядали просто красивими словами на
папері А щоб дійсно це були конкретні
інструменти до дій візьмемо Для прикладу
перша навичка серед десяти які
перелічені на довольському економічному
форумі це аналітичне мислення та
інноваційність
Для прикладу
на слайді ви бачите назви курсів які
створені для того щоб прокачувати цю
навичку курс логічно та стратегічне
мислення курс дата сайт курс Google
Shift давайте наступний слайд покажу
трішечки як вони виглядають
Так це курс який діти в наших приватних
школах вивчають з першого класу це
реальні початки дати знань з пов'язані з
зі сферою it це реальна робота з даними
це прокачка саме тихня тих навичок які
необхідні в сучасному світі і світі
майбутньому давайте трішечки проростаємо
приклади Ось так виглядають Workbook це
курс вамовий Так тут ми одразу
покриваємо необхідну навичку володіння
державною та іноземними мовами Тобто ми
навчаємо дітей навчатись і російською і
англійською діти дійсно починають
працювати з даними вже з першого класу
спочатку воно виглядає як
робота з папером з вирізаннями
сортуваннями вручну далі
далі давайте ще то це просто
візуалізація Ось так от виглядає як
дітки будують діаграми їм це надзвичайно
цікаво
але вже починають працювати з програмами
на планшетах в комп'ютері і так далі
тобто фактично ми розвиваємо ту навичку
яка необхідно в сучасності далі знову ж
таки аналітичне мислення і
інноваційність ми прокачуємо таким
курсом як Google
з базовими формулами та функціями Google
Shift діаграмами дажбовнами з імпортом
даних які оновлюються автоматично знову
ж таки це те що необхідно прокачувати
вже зараз і далі
і дасть дітей далі рухаємося
мислення так далі Коли ми переглядаємо
ті ж навички які затверджені там на
довольському економічному форумі ми
розуміємо що здатність мислити це те що
буде відрізнятися людину вірш штучного
інтелекту ще дуже-дуже довго тому що
зараз у нас з'явився величезний
конкурент це штучний інтелект і Нам
потрібно все далі І далі відходити від
виховання виконавчого документування і
виконувати людей зі стратегічним та
логічним мисленням Тому вже зараз в
наших навчальних курсах програмах Ми
створюємо такі курси як логічне та
стратегічне мислення
креативне мислення емпатія та
ненасильницька спілкування приблизно
Остап виглядають лепбуки як зараз
зображення на екрані
інклюзивне мислення допитливість Тобто
це фактично розвиток різних типів
мислення практичного товаристкість так
Тобто ми розуміємо що саме різні типи
мислення Ми повинні розвивати дітей вже
зараз як умова активніше для того Чим
більше ми будемо це робити Тим
продовж життя також вже пані Валентина
згадувала про це це те що також
необхідно закладати в школі перебивати
цю здатність навчатись постійно бо вже
ніколи не буде
українці коли ми отримали одні професії
дали дітям одну професію І вони з нею
йдуть все життя Все це потрібно прийняти
такого вже ніколи не буде І ми повинні
навчити їх вчитися постійно що ми маємо
вже зараз для того щоб діти могли цьому
навчатися скажімо курси лідерства за
Книгою всім навичок Стівена Кові
це всім звичок високоефективних
підлітків Також ми маємо Вербук і курси
про які я вже сказала про розвиток
різних типів мислення і маємо курс
розвиток емоційного інтелекту там емоцій
той момент всі ми також знаємо що це
зараз стає Більш важливим там IQ
важливіший ніж IQ так от і Для прикладу
на екрані знову ж таки курс як виглядає
наш курс освіти емоцій він також
починається з першого класу і
ще краще буде розвинутий прокачаний
емоцій
ний інтим
конкурентноспроможнішою буде людина
це приклад курсу лідер мені уже про
нього трішечки сказала
наступне
наступну необхідна навичка так яку ми
також повинні нині концентруватися це
спілкування державної мови зараз ця
особливо важлива і тут потрібно робити
ще додатковий акцент і окрім державного
стандарту ми додаємо додаткові курси
такі як публічні виступи толераторство
креативне письмо дебати можемо трішки
полистати теж слайди Подивіться приклади
як вони виглядають
Ось таким є курс про ораторство публічні
виступим креатив для письма копірайтом
фактично курс призначений для якісного
володіння усною письмовою мовою Тобто це
те що більше ніж просто там базовий
стандарт в мові наступна навичка
необхідна ініціативність і
підприємця що ми говоримо про розвиток
уміння генерувати нові ідеї ініціативи
втілювати їх в життя і виховувати цю
навичку дітям та для цього
У нас є створений курс Ok Google
професії і навички майбутнього
давайте далі покажемо Як він виглядає це
фактично футорологія та профорієнтація
Так зараз ми повинні дітям показувати
про ті спеціальності які будуть їх
чекати тоді коли ви закінчать школу
[музика]
фоторології що
в них відсотків існуючих професій
про того всього що ми бачимо Зараз
навколо дуже багато з цього не буде Ми
повинні показати дітям А що буде яку
сферу знанням потрібно освоювати де
можна себе шукати які навички для цього
потрібно собі в прокачувати для цього
створений Власне цей курс і це приклад
саме такої навички
все друзі Я не буду зараз зупинятися на
інше сонце Просто хочеться сказати про
те що
Чим більше ми будемо робити
експериментів Чим більше ми будемо
дивитися в майбутнє аналізувати
фоторологів аналізувати сучасні компанії
бізнес-тренди які впроваджувати все це в
освіту тим кориснішими ми будемо для
нашого основного клієнта і будемо
Пам'ятати про те що наш основний клієнт
- це саме дитина випускний наших
експертів Дякую друзі у нас наступний
учасника асоціації Віктор ларинський
засновник альтернативного проекту І
взагалі ідеолог альтернативної освіти в
Україні
будь ласка
Доброго дня
Я хочу спочатку сьогоднішні свої
ступ вдома і фрази
[музика]
впадаєш Тайна якого всі дуже добре
знають що можливо
ефективно розв'язати проблему чи якусь
задачу Якщо ви будете знаходитися на
тому ж самому рівні на якому вона
створена
і
здавалось би питання яке я сьогодні
презентую лібералізація
умов ліцензування для
малих освітніх проектів яких безліч в
Україні це дуже просте формально таке і
процесне питання але на мою думку
Воно знаходиться в зовсім іншій площині
і це це інша площина це питання до нас з
вами бо ми є держава Україна якою ми
хочемо бачити Україну через 10-20 50
років
і тут встає питання
візії нашого майбутнього як держави яку
створювати і цю державу буду створювати
наші діти які зараз йдуть в
нашій освітні заклади в нашій освітній
проекти і той путь який він той Шлях
який вони пройдуть в цих на початку
своєї освіти їм дійсно прийдеться
іти шляхом освіти протягнув свого життя
який шлях ми їм покажемо як ми цей
поможемо
стати
свідомими на ньому І
він покаже якою буде Україна
для них і для нас через якийсь час ми
зараз знаходимось дуже гарному становищі
дійсно бренд Україна він в світі зараз
просто тут і
бренд української освіти також є дуже
вдячні пані Валентині що вона сьогодні
презентацію цю зробила
Це є також дуже важливою складовою цього
самого бренду який ми вивезли за межі
нашої держави завдяки нашим освітянам і
нашим дітям і
нам потрібно підтримати його не
пропустити цей момент і розвинути його і
я просто впевнений що за якусь за якийсь
час багато освітян всього світу будуть
їздити на до України і
навчатися в нас вона дійсно є ще
показати але що нам на чому нам потрібно
сконцентруватися потрібно нам
сконцентруватися на тому щоб якщо ми
говоримо про те що Україна
до України найважливіша це люди то нам
потрібно сконцентруватися на
інтивілізованій освіті на
індивідуалізованому підході до освіти
наших людей наших малих людей маленьких
людей це наших дітей і
це дуже велике завдання
інша тема - це
[музика]
ми зовсім мені здається забагато років
забули про те що саме роль освітніх
проєктів це виховання перш за все
виховання людини
як
потім вона буде створювати цю і буде
складовою цієї держави
для того щоб це все відбулось
якісно Нам потрібен якісний вчитель і
[музика]
дуже багато уваги на мою думку зараз нам
потрібно приділити тому щоби
саме підняти Престиж професії вчителя
щоб наших вчителів це були дійсно елітою
нашого суспільства
і останнє дуже важлива річкою хоче щоб
ми процентрувались в нашій освіті це на
взаємодії
освітніх проєктів з суспільством з
батьками з громадою вони просто мають
стати
освітніми центрами для тієї громади в
якій для якої вони працюють з дітьми
якої вони
співпрацюють і
тоді ми маємо дуже добрі шанси отримати
дійсно освіченого спільного
так далі я хочу трохи зупинитись на
кожному з цих моментів Ну якщо говорити
про індивідуалізовану освіту то
нам потрібно створити дуже багато
різноманітних просторів в яких наші діти
будуть
показувати
будуть мати змогу
відчувати себе комфортно показувати свою
відмінність
[музика]
показуватись бо всі люди різні наші діти
також різні їм потрібні
різноманітні доброзичливі середовища які
будуть допомагати їм
їх ще не досить свідомому житті
[музика]
цю свідомість створювати і тому Чим
менше шаблонів ми будемо використовувати
чим більше кількість людей надамо змогу
чи більше кількість проєктів надамо
змогу
працювати на освітньому
ринку України тим більше наших людей
наших дітей зможуть індивідуально себе
проявити І дійсно прожити це дитинство
щасливо І випадувати із себе щасливих
людей які будуть потім реалізовувати і
себе і держава Україна і представляти її
як бренд в у всьому світі і Ніхто з них
не захоче
збігати з цієї країни вони захочуть
створювати виховувати своїх дітей Саме
тут вони захочуть створювати цю країну
бо ця країна буде для них і ця країна
допомогла їм стати таким як вони є
інше наступна річ це
освіта Ми повинні розуміти що школа вона
у вчителів
школа - це не якась будівля в школу
впроваджують наших вчителів і без
якісних вчителів без того щоб приділити
цьому дуже велику увагу перш за все їх
вихованням їх побудові
ну неможливо говорити про
масштабну якісну загальну освіту для
наших дітей і можливо говорити про
якесь якісне
майбутнє для держави України в світі
потрібно підіймати Престиж цієї професії
ці люди повинні бути дійсно
високооплачуваними
держава повинна робити має робити все що
тільки її змозі щоб показувати в цьому
суспільству що саме це люди є еліта з
іншого боку ці люди і повинні стати
елітою і працювати над собою
Для цього вони мають мати час
в школах займатись не якимось
формальними речами Вони мають займатись
в школі
розвитком допомоги в розвитку своїх
учнів Вони мають концентруватись на тому
щоб Якщо говорити про антивіталізовану
освіту мають концентруватись на тому щоб
побудувати побудувати програму
навчання програму розвитку
кожного окремого класу і кожного окре
учнів Вони мають концентруватись на тому
щоб розвивати себе або Без цього вони не
зможуть бути
ефективними в сучасному світі бути
ефективними сучасними вчителями
все інше якраз і має за них зробити
держава якщо її це потрібно і це і
повинен бути її сервіс вчителі мають
сконцентруватися на своїх учнях і
сконцентруватися на самому розвитку
якщо ми отримуємо цю освітянську еліту
то тоді вже буде доволі просто нам
говорити про те що
школа буде
школа як загальна такі термін
заклад освіти що він буде
дійсно
центром
освіти для громади в якій він існує сама
громада буде тягнутися до цього
освітнього центру сама громада буде
тягнутися до цієї
освітянської еліти з багатьма своїми
проблемами Своїми питаннями про дітей і
про майбутнє і про своє навчання і
багатьма із питаннями про розвиток
судової громади
і це Ну так як
працювала в доволі багато часу раніше і
цього зовсім немає зараз бо немає Ну ми
не маємо просто цієї освітянської лінії
для чого це важливо для того що
взагалі-то
виховання дитини це безперервний процес
протягом
всього
часу яку який дитина
зростає і це не тільки а в закладі
освіти вона перебуває тільки окремий ну
дуже обмежений час і дуже важлива Роль
тут батьків дуже важлива Роль у сім'ї і
нам Важливо щоб
саме в унісон працювали
цей трикутник учень вчитель і батьки він
повинен працювати ефективно і тоді ми
отримуємо просто
вибух
якісної якісного процесу
освіти наших дітей
для цього нам потрібно працювати з
батьками для цього Просвіта батьків бо
це також дуже важливо задача
чому я все це показував В своїй
презентації тому що
На мою думку саме маленькі сімейні
проєкти яких зараз в Україні Ну дійсно
тисячі
просто держава про них не знає і чомусь
не дуже хоче знати
саме вони є носіями цієї філософії бо
саме освідчені люди які взяли на себе
для себе відповідальність не захотіли
зробити якісь гроші а взяли на себе
відповідальну діяльність до роботи
вчителя це робота
на мою думку
найбільш складна і найбільш
відповідальна взагалі з усіх
[музика]
професії виконуваних робіт які взагалі
існують в світі якщо вже людина взяла за
це ще й Взяла на себе відповідальність
за те щоб
взяти до цього проекту і запропонувати
прийти якимось іншим сім'ям якимось
іншим дітям ну то це над відповідальну
людину з неї точки зору і вже за це
держава має бути їй вдячна
І тому Ну
по-перше держава вам зможе вирішити дуже
багато питань
[музика]
місць наявних місць для освіти дітей які
їй потрібно створювати
тому що за
нашою конституцією всі ми всі наші діти
всі ми маємо право на
освіту і
багато маленьких проектів можуть просто
Закрити цю незважаючи на те що в цих
проектах 20-30 дітей десь 10
десь 50
вони можуть закрити дуже-дуже багато
цих освітніх місць і На мою думку
приділити увагу цим проектам і допомогти
їм надати сервіс допомогу додатково
фінансування це просто те що
має бути
Одним із завдань для держави на
сьогоднішній момент
якщо подивитися на питання вже з
формальної точки зору Ну тут ми бачимо
ці ліцензійні умови які зараз є це
кадрові Я хочу пройтись три трішечки по
кожній з них з огляду на все те що я
розповідаю В даний вимоги до
педагогічних
[музика]
працівників Ми багато говоримо про
якість Педа
які в наших педагогічних вищих вона на
думку багатьох дуже-дуже низька
мотивація цих людей дуже і дуже низька
То навіщо ми ставимо це е-е як обмеження
будь-які ліцензійні умови - це обмеження
навіщо ми ставимо цей як обмеження для
доступу наших дітей до
авторитетних і в'язкісних дорослих які
можуть
дійсно чомусь навчити Серед таких своїм
чеснотам за своїм такі свої мудрості Ані
завдяки тому що в них є чим вони нема
диплома тобто папірця про
педагогічну вищу освіту
приміщення Ну це взагалі пане міністр це
взагалі Ну просто смішне питання бо ну
на прикладі нашого закладу В тому році
ми забили експеримент ми взагалі середню
школу запустили без будь-якого
приміщення до війни на жаль
Тільки 5 з половиною місяців ми про
займалися але
діти в п'ятому класі зустрічались 200
зустрічались в бібліотеці на верантії
Булгакова в театрі на Подолі
в парку вднг в
майстернях
художників
просто до вулиці на пленері на
спортивних майданчиках вони кожний день
зустрічалися кожний день Це був Було
якесь нове місце
туди приїжджали їх вчителі
ми створювали на кожний день
їм цікаву програму і вони спілкувались з
цими вчителями цих просторах це давали
доволі гарний
доволі
цікаве середовище в якому вони могли
обговорювати на його базі
питання ну в якій вже стосуються там
того чи іншого предмету тобто історію ми
взагалі вивчали на вулиці на вулицях
міста Києва і ну це нормально з одного
боку повертаємось до того що школа вона
у вчителі і
Я не дуже розумію навіщому прив'язуємо
ліцензію на впровадження освітньої
діяльності до якоїсь будівлі тобто є
якісь розмальовані будівлі в якій дуже
багато грошей ми вклали але внутри цих
будівель працюють радянські вчителів
зовсім не мотивовані не люблячи багато з
них не люблять дітей
але ж ліцензію ми отримуємо до цієї
будівлі є
проєкти мережеві в яких ну саме все
тримається на
харизмі на Аурі самого власника
навіщо йому отримувати ліцензію 5 разів
коли він робить таку добру справу і
робить чи в одному місті чи в декількох
містах
5 різних закладів освіти з тією самою
філософією і кожний раз од неї те саме
він якби повинен державі довести щоб він
створює власний проект
щодо ну наявності підручників і
бібліотеки це взагалі питання таке що
зараз все є в електронному вигляді
навіщо воно все ще є
ліцензійними умовами Я не розумію
медичне обслуговування зараз вже пляшків
дозволили
мати співпрацю з
медичними закладами але для дитячих
садочків Наскільки я знаю все що
потрібно мати
медичного працівника Ну я також не
досить розумію всіх приватних закладі
наприклад всі вчителі як правило
проходять
кожний рік сертифікацію по домедичній
допомозі що там допоможе це медсестра
без вищої освіти Я взагалі не розумію
всі вони мають
договори з клініками коли отримують
дійсно професійну консультацію в якихось
складних питаннях
організація харчування це просто підміна
понять На мою думку Тобто ми замість
того щоб
перевірити якісний і смачне харчування
ми перевіряємо наявність процедур за
восьми вчителів там програмами
передумовими Якщо ці
купапамперців закладі є то держава
вважає що все там добре на кухні
називається
таргани можуть там голуб їхати АА
як на мене то
Ну набагато краще коли діти зранку
прокуджають біжуть на кухні говорять там
Галю А що у нас там сьогодні на завтраки
можна на сніданок А можна тоді допоможу
можна
Там ми задавали створемо якийсь
конкурсну там по перевертанню млинців на
сковородці
і там газ зробили на завтра те і те і
вони там дуже дійсно Коросно Здорово
харчуються бо батьки зараз цим
займаються
що там ще у нас ну наявність веб-сайту з
інформацією не всі проєкти хочуть бути
побічними Я не розумію чому це повинно
стати чому це обов'язково вимога
Ну і забезпечено доступності для осіб з
інвалідністю також на ці проекти
працюють з інвалідами з інвалі проекти
їм дуже складно це матеріальні витрати
їм дуже складно
витримати ці умови вимоги коли вони
можливо у них там з 10 дітей 0 дітей з
інвалідністю і вони їм не планують
долучати таких дітей
так ну
хочу сказати то чи що насамперед держава
рухається потроху з
2017-18 року потроху тут рухається
в бік лібералізації але дуже-дуже
повільно поки що ми отримали як
ліцензування у вигляді декларування
тобто заявляємо що ми ці всі вимоги
виконуємо через рік приходять люди і
вимагають
папірців замість того щоб оцінити дійсно
проект
Ну і моя моя думка
ще три коротких слайди вибачаюсь Моя
думка що отримання але ліцензії повинно
стати на сьогодні не обов'язково права
бо вона ж е-е саме право на освіту
гарантує держава не обов’язок освіти
якщо вже почитати Чесно кажучи
Конституції то її отримання ліцензії
повинна стати Хто хоче то і отримує
ліцензію і потім
цією ліцензією ну завойовує своїх
клієнтів у вигляді батьків а хто Для
кого це не є важливим але вони видають
гарний результат то чому б ні
[музика]
диференціювати можна доволі просто за
кількістю учнів в таких проектах і також
можна обмежити видачу
атестата на про освіту для таких
закладів Я впевнений що І зараз багато
молився закладів вони вирішуються
питання просто атестацію своїх учнів в
державних
ліцензованих закладах так скажемо І
абсолютно успішно всі ці процеси
відбуваються ніякої проблеми з цим немає
тобто Ніхто за права видачі атестатів не
ганяється
я хочу сказати про підвищення
громадських організацій і наприкінці бо
багато чого
[музика]
ефективно можуть дійсно робити
громадські організації це і атестація
шкіл і атестація учнів і про писання
який якоїсь нормативної бази і вони
можуть Просто допомогти держави зняти з
неї весь цей
найефективно реалізованими державою як
правило всі ці питання
держава повинна виконувати свою головну
роль вона повинна надавати сервіси
надавати фінансування або саме держава
збирає податки з платників податків і
чесно і справедливо
цими грошима розпоряджатися
для всіх повинні бути різні умови Дякую
велике дякую Віктор для кожного учасника
асоціації але мені злинська Експерт у
сфері безпеки дітей
будь ласка
[музика]
увагу до питань безпеки дітей підлітків
взагалі у сфери безпеки і коли
навчальних закладах це важливо Це
дошкільний навчальний заклад або
шкільний навчальний навчальний заклад є
приватної форми власності або державної
охорони власності питання головне -
основне в тому полягає що більшість вас
підтримуюся з цією ситуацією коли
потрібно мати викриття
тобто у нас наразі визначено одним
словом в державі не дуже
використовується тому що їх просто
анально майже немає по всій країні і
кожний проект зараз для того щоб
працювати надалі і розпочинати свій
навчальний рік Він має забезпечити
безпечні умови не тільки для персоналу А
так само і для дітей і для підлітків які
знаходяться на території цього періоду і
особливо важливий момент є те що ці всі
укриття вони зараз проходять атестацію
від державної служби але ми маємо
розуміти що не всі маленькі проекти вони
мають змогу за такий забезпечити ці всі
необхідні люди Чому тому що більшість з
них не мають власних приміщення ті які
види використовують не були побудовані з
урахуванням тих всіх виробників які
зараз у нашій Україні існують
тому мені здається що Варто звернути
увагу на варіанти рішення які необхідно
для того щоб власне забезпечити більшу
безпеку існуючих умовах під час навчання
дійсно ми маємо розуміти що наш бізнес
безпечно дитині поріза батьками вдома
але при цьому коли йдеться про
навчальний проект ми маємо розуміти що
відповідальність триває на керівника
цього проекту І власне на вчителів які
знаходяться по розділі в інший ми маємо
створити ці умови і кожен виходить з
цієї ситуації або заключаючи договори
різноманітні або якимось чином
намагаючись оформити відповідне
приміщення для того щоб знову ж таки
забезпечити необхідні умови для того щоб
надавати освітні послуги
другий момент на який я вважаю необхідно
за таких умов звертати увагу це
наявності комплектованої правильним
чином аптечки тому що знову ж таки
містокнулися ситуацію коли не всі якщо
не заходи
працюють тільки з дорослими а деякими
документами вони не застосовуються для
дітей взагалі не передбаченні це їх
використання і таким чином Нам необхідно
сформувати такі аптечки на певної
допомоги які б могли використовуватись
так само для дітей різних вікових груп
наявність у складі медичної сестри як
зазвичай тут це дійсно бажано для
більшості батьків Тому що під час
навчання в лекції коли побудувати вони
кажуть що їм так банальності темніші
тому що це є фахівець відповідно і
медичної освіти і бази на медичну освіту
яким разі чого має відповідальність
призначати і надавати невідкладну
допомогу
тому випадку коли вона необхідна але я
бажаю що також ми можемо розглядати
варіанти для невеличких проектів
додаткове навчання персоналу саме до
медичної допомоги тому що у нас є навіть
вітаміни з самою визначеною що таке є
відкладної допомоги що таке домедичну
допомогу і чим вони відрізняються одна
від одної
можливо питання вирішення базової
потреби для дітей
Щодо мене надання невідкладної допомоги
разом необхідності це медичне
страхування на жаль за умови єговиків в
країні медичне страхування працює ну
оленикового потужності але це досить
який є У
багатьох країнах світу і ми маємо його
також використовувати у проекти і
проекти для того щоб знову ж таки
по-перше розподіляти відповідальності
по-друге дійсно надавати якісні послуги
у разі якщо вони потрібні
крім того у цих умовах які зараз будуть
працювати навчальні проекти і
розпочинаються навчальний рік також
важливий момент там є проведення
інструктажів з пункту з тої поведінки
яким чином має діяти персонал навчальних
закладів І власне саме діти як вони
мають кількість під час локації або
повітряної дороги і Хочу зазначити що на
жаль існуючих умовах коли є велика
відстань від найбільшого укриття
один вищого відкриття і У даний час має
ключове значення і На жаль немає єдиного
алгоритмів які можна використовувати
тому що це в кожному проекті дуже
величезні питання І відстань у всіх
різних особливо коли йдеться про те що у
власному проєкті немає власного укриття
і вони можуть користуватися тим якими
найбільшими картами але при цьому маємо
розуміти що відстань у 800 метрів і 80
метрів це перш за все час і знову ж таки
Коли проводиться навчання
дуже часто діти хтось скопів У всіх
різні можуть бути виникнути потреби і ми
маємо розуміти як люди що один чи два
вихователя це Іноді дуже складно
організувати тому знову ж таки
інструктаж стосується не тільки
проведення стосовно персоналу але також
дуже класно коли це все під час
навчального процесу або довго печатку
пізнавання
[музика]
проводить тому що як звучить дос
від роботи тренування - це якби
насправді вирішують 99% взагалі
будь-яких ситуацій які виникають тобто
якщо дитина або підліток або доросла
людина потре сподобалося кілька разів ці
логарифні дії набагато краще
спрацьовують у непередбачуваних умовах
якщо це запитання підготуватися і
підтримуватись і так само з досвідом
можу
сказати дуже класно це сприймають
особливо коли це відбувається у вигляді
гри або якихось конкурсів тобто з
ігрової за ігровою методики ну тобто не
казати подивимося погано все погано і
додатково ще підвищувати фактори
страхівку А але при цьому Ми маємо
розуміти що якщо це буде все надаватися
в якості гри то найбільш ефективно це
спрацьовує людей підлітків Тому що їм
так цікавіше і майже ніколи вони не
уникають цієї можливості навчатися
додатково
так само коли йдеться про інструктаж Я б
хотіла зауважити що зараз з точки зору
дитячого психології дуже багато клієнтів
виникнення яких раніше не виникає
наприклад була історія була дівчинка
просто почувши банальний звук від
повітряного кульки яка лопнула так вони
він це спрацювало асоціація ніж вона
пострілі на виборних і таке інше є діти
тобто котрі реагують на звук повітряної
тривоги і таких випадків будуть далі
більше Оскільки діти дійсно травмовані
психологічне і мають дійсно
Нечуй працювати не тільки власний
педагоги але є родини які зазнали Але
були
участь на жаль
багатьох ситуаціях пов'язаних з
обстрілами і різними іншими ситуаціями
але при цьому Я Хочу наголосити що якщо
відповідно вчинок підготувати педагогів
і пройти відповідні навчання А також
організувати відповідним чином безпечно
просто для дітей підлітків ці травми і
наслідки від цієї каліватизації можна
значно знизити і таким чином додатково
убезпечити умови для того щоб діти
проходили не тільки навчання на мобільні
навчальні реабілітацію від тих всіх
важких подій яким довелося стати
свідками або їм довелося переживати і
також наостанок Хочу додати що у нас є
ще один Фактор на який вважають набагато
людей оскільки взагалі на території
частина нашої країни де то кажуть не до
цього це є інформація персональна
інформація і збереження персональних
даних особливо це стосується тих
територій які були захоплені зараз
вважають окупованою йдеться про локальну
базу даних та рахунки які мають бути
приміщення і безпечно і все або
зберігатись у безпечному середовищі для
того щоб вони не Потрапили у небажання
руху тому що знову ж таки ми маємо
розуміти що інформація про батьків там
родини про різноманітні
особливості здоров'я і такі якщо а також
що стосується інформації про працівників
це персональні дані які потребують
додаткового захисту тому будь ласка
звертайте увагу і з ну Зверніть увагу на
цей Фактор тому що зазвичай
в будь-якому проекті база даних
регулюється приміщенні цього проекту
деякі проекти цій інформації копіюють на
інші
сховища але при цьому коли йдеться про
те тут зараз треба обмежити доступ у
більшості проектів такому можливості
немає
і все це
має змовлення впроваджувати або тільки
власних проекту або адміністратор який
займається адміністратив
адмініструванням цих всіх позбавлення
тому будь ласка це ще один важливий який
слід звертати увагу і якщо Ця інформація
є Ну у вільному доступна але при цьому у
вас немає змоги певним чином обмежити
доступ будь ласка звертальними словами
тому що персональні дані вони зараз
користуються дуже суттєвим попитом і
можуть також бути використані
злостіками і
ворогами для того щоб навести ще більший
шкоди не тільки власне безпосередньо там
приміщенню або оснащенні проектувати
саме людям і дітям які навчаються які
перебувають у сенсаційному навчальному
закладі і знову ж таки виступав на
психологічні паспортів роботи в умовах
військового стану зрозуміти що це такий
дуже потужно виклику оскільки я вже
казала раніше батьки хвилюються
але шляхом
[музика]
впровадження певних алгоритмів і
тренувань ми можемо забезпечити більшу
безпеку в
умовах якої серйозної ситуації і знову ж
таки вимагайтесь
зробити не таким суттєвим не таким
кричучим вплив на ауксибічної емоційному
психологічної і всі наші стало дітей для
того щоб знову ж таки наша країна може
змогу розвиватись і більш якісно бути
готовою до всіх важливих викликів Дякую
за увагу
Дякуємо Олена і останній учасник на
сьогоднішній день
Він у нас підключається онлайн це
учасника асоціації заснованих корпорації
грам Володимир співаковський Володимир
ви нас чуєте
зараз відрегулюємо
[музика]
сейчас Меня слышно сейчас взагалі
прекрасно
1 сентября мы собрались и решаем очень
важные вопросы Потому что они эти
вопросы связаны с образованием они
касаются уже Нет только Украины потому
что прямо вот наши дни вот в это время
происходит градиозные изменение э-э
основопологающей фундаментальных а-а
постулатов и принципах которые
должно определить куда это дворазование
должно двигаться главное
образования и не случайно потому что
посмотреть вокруг Давайте посмотрим Что
делается в мире И до чего довело до
образования на котором выросли Поколение
людей в разных странах И окажется что
это мало кому подходит мало кому
нравится поэтому поодигма образование
скорее всего будет меняться и когда мы
изучили этот вопрос оказалось что для
того чтобы говорить о будущего
образовании Так я заглавил свой доклад
нужно
искать не ответы на вопросы а как вот
меня учили очень давно мои великие
учителя нужно правильно поставить
вопросы надо совместр сформулировать
вопросы и тогда можете кажется что
ответы на них покажет нам путь куда
нужно идти И тогда тяжкое тебе
основатели школ все детей которые
[музика]
образования и будет легче и со
школьниками с учителями и вообще
самооценкой своего дела и свои
собственно и так я не случайно загналил
свое выступление яке будущее образование
с такими с такой цифровукой семь
w77 Потому что э-э
если знать ответы на вот эти семь
поставленных вопросах о которых я кратко
сейчас расскажу то кажется что мы сможем
сформировать ту модель образования как в
нашей стране так отдельной школе а
возможно уже Принято такая концепция для
развития образования в мире так главное
первые вопрос из этих седьми
[музика]
А зачем учиться
Потому что если не имеет ответы на этот
вопросы всё остальное становится
бессмысленным потому что учиться можно
для себя для того чтобы уехать за
границу для того чтобы участвовать
восстановление своей страны для того
чтобы я просто так получился можно
потому что друзья пошли и Я пошёл
учиться там в школу или в университет
или куда но в зависимости от цели
полагания возникает мотивация потому что
на разные ответы Зачем учиться будет
другое контент обучение и Он уже
диференцируется нельзя просто так всему
учить и-и в ногу Как не будете
день-небудь и так первые вопрос А зачем
учиться это сильнейший мотиватор ведь мы
с вами люди отобразования которые
переживают за образование главные
главное что ищет и пытаются найти в
нашего ученика
ты не можем найти это мотивацию то есть
процентов 20 детей мотивированные
учиться процента 80 не мотивиро что с
одним делать оказывается если все время
поддерживать траекторию с внутренним
вопросом ребёнка А зачем ты учишься Даже
если он отвечает не попады как-то не так
всё равно надо навязывать парадигбо А
зачем ты учишься она может меняться хоть
каждый день неделя но всё равно она
должна быть Как быть полонини и это
работает то есть постоянно как бы вот в
классе висит ответ вопрос Зачем учиться
зачем ты учишься и знаете принимает на
5-10 раз принимают потому что после
первого вопроса а зачем учиться
возникает следующий вопрос
чому учить соответствии там с программой
Министерства с программой школы с
программой какой-то навязанной А чего
ребёнок хочет учиться потому что там где
он хочет там учится он будет и тут
оказывается интересная метеорнофоза
произошла с образование Я например
человек но погружали в образованию как и
всем с вами я всегда считал что школы
предназначенные для того чтобы давать
знания детям то есть знания Как бы это
первом месте но в последние два года
пообщавшись С несколькими сотнями
родителей которые с которым я общаюсь Я
выяснил для себя удивительную вещь
неожиданно было сначала больно но я
понял что они права родителя не мудрые
люди они образования не ставят теперь на
первое место на первое место у них
безопасность и понятно почему
честно говоря я думал что образование
будет хотя бы на втором месте
но оказалось что на второе место
неожиданно вышла социализация вот что не
требует они хотят чтобы ребёнок был
безопасности и так как он часто бывает в
онлайне и не так не так часто не так
часто общения с э-э сверстюками с
друзьями то общения выходит на второе
место только на третие образование на
только на третье знания и тогда я
перестроил весь учебный процес и э-э как
бы три Единая получилось такое а-а
образование на вопрос чего учиться и
безопасности как бы здоровью и самого
утверждения многими психологическим
вещам второе - это социализация - это
коммуникация общения третье здание
конечно же в самом лучшем проявлении
которые мы тоже только можем дать третий
вопрос А где учиться Ага вот с чем
сегодня забоченные родители потому что
то ли в онлайне то ли в офлайн то ли
смешанное образование тоже домашнее То
ли ещё какое-то кто МНО через границы то
есть как совместить как организовать
ответ на вопрос где чтобы он был
оптимально Да тут общего рецепта Нет но
мы для себя увидели что это дело семьи
это уже родители в соответствии со своим
а-а пониманием ситуации приоритетом и
себе этими выбирают тот формат который
им нужен в принципі выбор есть мне очень
хорошим понятно война идёт но тем не
менее как-то сложить пасл они сегодня
могут четвёртый вопрос 4-й вопрос а
раньше Он звучал так А кто будет учить
потому что случителя межбеда
таким образом пониманием как бы может
быть не со все профессиональные э-э
хороших учителей А их все меньше и
меньше и пополнение в нашей реды
не Откуда в будущем потому что профессия
ну сложная профессия слабо флаг мала
оплачиваемая и пополнение из наших
университетов педагогических не всех
радует и так если раньше обговорил э-э
кто будет учить вот есть проблема с
учителями то сейчас я переформулировал и
называют от вопрос А у кого учи
получению и потреблению применению
знания по увеличивается в рази
пятый вопрос
Как учиться
технология конечно мы с вами их знаем
десятки можете их сотні ну сегодня есть
уже такие технологии на работу мы
современные много до вопрос Как учиться
так чтобы знания усваивались так чтобы
они были применины чтобы они были не как
треш и не в воздухе нет трубу чтобы они
были полезные но хотя бы процентов на 80
а не на 20 как сейчас Это одна из
основных задач
не принята об этом говорить Но это самый
важный вопрос который задают родители а
в частности вот когда они поступают в
школу или ищут репетиторы или учителя
это шестой вопрос это How much Сколько
стоит И кто за обучение должен заплатить
родители
государства ли корпорации
бизнес-линди Ну это очень важный вопрос
Я думаю что его обходить не стоит
решение существуют но у меня сегодня
осталось пару минут поэтому я не буду
даже кипить сейчас рассказывать если
будет возможно сказать его следующие
может быть нужно обсудить вопрос Кто
должен платить за Образование и сколько
оно должно стоить хорошее образование
и так Наконец седьмой вопрос седьмой
вопрос А что мы получим в результате А
какой будет результат что будет являться
результатом образования если мы выполнем
все
этим иметь ответы на все эти всем
вопросов и это тоже самое важное потому
что это вопрос нет цена это вопрос не
только знаний знаний бывают современные
знания
фундаментальная - это вопросы знания
языка сегодня надо включать английский
язык уже в постулатых параметра
тех-6-семей це результатов которые
которые ребёнок должен засечь а
разговарителем не важно какой ребёнка
будет характер а разведение важно за
какую у него будет эмоциональный
интеллект вместе с м коефіцієнтом
интересов интересно так их и так
оказывается что это система вопросов
составляет от пазл который уверенно не у
треба двіжок система мирового
образования в глобальном мире Ну и
конечно в глобальный мир сам по себе
хотя бы остановимся частью этого
глобального мира но Нам нужно переживать
за своим страну поэтому они нас наверно
8 вопросов Я бы его вставил там во
второй вопрос чего учится но он идёт
отдельно восьмой вопрос это то что
сегодня несколько миллионов наших детей
подверглись по травматическим стресовым
раствором расстройством и этому нужно
вроде когда уделять внимание но как
пострадавших дітей
нет столько врачей психолога мне у нас в
стране не в мире прежние протоколы уже
негодяться и нужно разрабатывать
какие-то новые подходы которые позволяют
быстро доступно комфортно и массово
большое количество детей приводить в
какое-то национальное психологическое
равновесия Ну вот мы свой раз тут
Говорят мы как разрабатываем разработали
систему уже за границей она э-э
пользуются спросом и для наших детей и
для тех детей которые которых странах
наше находятся Дети и я думаю что нужно
это будет внимание это будет внимание
наше Министерства я считаю что это
отлично Это здорово что вопрос птср
сегодня остановится одним из первым это
это внимание уделяет юний все поэтому
внимание уделяет даже первая Леди
Лена зеленская которая
психологической защите наших детей и я
думаю что это сегодня становится таким
восьмим вопросов на ряду с теми о
которых я поговорил это вопрос А зачем
учиться это вопрос чего учится главное
из него вытекает Как учиться где учиться
а сколько это должно стоит И какое Мы в
конце концов с вами получим результат
если вона удасться получить правильный
ответы Хороший ответ на этим
основопологающих вы индементальных новых
вопросов Вы знаете этой может стать
реформой нашего образования передовой
потому что такого в мире молоково есть
оно размытая оно какой-то фрагментарная
потому что в будущем образование не може
состоять только из э-э расписание
предметов портфелей
бакалавриатов значит и прочих вещей они
уже устарели и надо искать новые э-э
пріоритеты новые траектории которые
приведут нас переформированные системы
образования и счастливого дня для детей
и приятного
удовлетворительному состоянию родителей
в том числе и учителей Спасибо вам за
внимание Я надеюсь что мы
во все оружия не смотря на все сложности
которые есть мы Все с вами Готовимся и я
думаю что не что не испортить нам слово
учебного года для э-э того чтобы
родители и дети и учителя и государства
были довольно
система образования Спасибо вам большое
Дякуємо Володимир вас можна слухати це
безкінечності Дякую
[музика]
друзі тобі я зараз
швидко зачитаю рекомендації які за
результатами сьогоднішньої конференції
ми
надаємо Міністерства освіти і потім ми
можемо вже закінчувати тож
виходячи з сьогоднішньої нашої зустрічі
робимо наступні висновки перше
приватна освіта це один з найбільших
роботодавців в Україні
роботодавців для
найбільш вразливих
Скажімо так категорії роботодавці
а друге приватна освіта потужний внутрі
[музика]
шні гімназії які саме будує школу або
садок а саме організовує процес сам
отримала і відповідно тоді Приват Це
величезне розвантаження для державного
бюджету
тобто витрати які мають внести
[музика]
А мені головне приватна освіта це
потужний рушник змін в освіті завдяки
[музика]
а-а змін в різних сферах авторські
програми курси непереновіші технології
методики найкраще викладачі системи їх
підготовки
системні менеджери керівників
відповідно в цій ситуації особливо в
умовах воєнного післявоєнного часу для
держави розвиток приватної освіти та її
заохочення
[музика]
а напрямки в яких потрібно рухатись
перше максимальне нерегуляція
починаючи від ліцензійних умов
дбр їх переглядів наприклад коли Там
розетка на рівні метр-80 ну тобто
доберіть ще 60-х років минулого століття
а також необхідно нагальна реформа
програми середньої та старшої школи а
також система дошкільної освіти
і жодне рішення не може готуватися
прийматись
[музика]
другим сприяння саморегуляції потрібно
закон про саморегулювання організації і
запровадити таку організацію в
приватному секторі освіти надання
функції акредитації програми курсів
харчування контролю організації роботи
під час локдаунів надзвичайних ситуацій
саморобні організації яка об'єднує
[музика]
більшість А це буде суттєвий Крок на
зустріч швидко і єбералізації
а третє максимальне захочення розвитку
приватної освіти
через
[музика]
компенсаторні освіти
держзамовлення в приватних школах
хасадах а не тільки вузах
оренда комунального
[музика]
розвиток державного приватного
партнерства з акцентом на
приватній четверте
[музика]
п'яте іноземна підтримка має
спрямованість в першу чергу на
заохочення підтримку
привестерів форматах державного
приватного партнерства
[музика]
ри а також підтримку закладів вчителів і
батьків зокрема мама
через механізми субвенцій компенсації
погашення боргів держзамовлення
30 корпоративних закладів грантової
підтримки
терміново-централізація освітньої сфери
ми маємо позбавитись всієї цієї
паперової тяганини яка зараз
суттєво ускладнює процес в ліцензованих
закладах
7 терміново вирішення ситуації з
тарифами за комунальні послуги для
закладів освіти порівняння розміру
тарифів долів іних організацій
або в оприлюднюємо тарифи до розміру
тарифів релігійних організацій або лише
школи стають релігійними організаціями а
освіта нашої релігії
восьмий терміново включення приватної
освіти для всіх колегіальних та дирей чи
органів Міністерства освіти місцевих
органів влади створення окремими
постійно діючої робочої групи з питань
приватної освіти при міністерстві для
реалізації всіх цих
[музика]
А у випадку врахування всіх цих
рекомендацій можна дійсно швидко
відновити
розмова Новому
рівні нашого освітній сферу а
головне це буде набагато дешевше для
бюджет вбудовано
[музика]
кількість осіб на отримання сторінок
підходів
до освіти
От такі рекомендації ми передаємо в
Міністерство якщо є Що додати ви мені
тоді напишіть я ще додам і ми разом ці
всі рекомендації передамо в Міністерства
офіційно від нашої сесії А наразі дякую
всім за участь
і до наступних зустрічей
[оплески]